hey youtubers is charlie so we learned
the titles for like the next block of
Game of Thrones episodes so this is
going to be a little bit of speculation
about that we already know a few things
but sometimes it's just fun to look at
the titles and just guess at what that
means sometimes it's a really big
metaphor for everything that's going on
sometimes it's a little bit simpler the
title of episode 2 is home so given what
happened in episode 1 you can guess what
that means for some of the different
characters that we'll probably see Sansa
thinking about Winterfell Daenerys is
stuck with the dose killeen she has a
new home even Ramsay is trying to
protect his new home which is Santa's
old home here's the actual synopsis bran
trains with a three-eyed Raven in King's
Landing Jamie advises Tommen in the East
Tyrion demands good news but ends up
having to make his own up at Castle
black the Nights Watch stands behind
Alliser thorne at Winterfell Ramsay
Bolton proposes a plan and over in the
Iron Islands Balon Greyjoy entertains
other proposals so I've already talked
about a couple of those other stories
but let's talk about the Ironborn we
haven't met your on Greyjoy yet but we
know we're going to see him he showed up
in the trailer so I'm hoping that he
actually peers in this episode because I
would say of all the Ironborn characters
even if you like fianc sister even if
you like Theon I think Euron Greyjoy is
going to be the more interesting person
I always felt like he co-opted one of
the villains storylines in the book so
I'm hoping he winds up being a more
antagonistic character especially when
you consider that the odd sister is more
for protagonist even though she's not
the nicest person she's a protagonist in
the way Jack and her Garza protagonist
like he kills a lot of people but he's
not an evil person so on the spectrum of
iron board I'm just I'm expecting your
uncle a joy to be like a
larger-than-life Ramsay type character
without being as crazy as Ramzi talking
about Tyrion we might get to see him
give that speech about dragons he
doesn't know a lot about dragon lore but
he definitely knows more than most
people in the books leading up to this
point he's actually been reading a lot
about dragons so they might just brush
over that there are a couple big
libraries in the world in none of them
are near marine like the next biggest
one is in a shy way over in the East
where Melisandre comes from that's also
where two nurses dragon eggs come from
but I'm never expecting the show to go
there there's just there's so much the
show is cut out that I'm not expecting
it to go to the Far East what about
Ramsay's plan though most people here
Ramsey
plan and they think pink letter if
you've never heard of the pink letter
it's just another name for what's called
the bastard letter where Ramsey in the
books sends a letter taunting Jon Snow
trying to goad him to come to Winterfell
because after reek and Jane pool who
Sansa is a stand-in for on the TV show
he thinks that they've gone to the wall
so like Roose Bolton said during episode
one you don't have Sansa you can't
produce an heir he wants them back this
might be the show's version of the pink
letter but since jon snow is still
chillin on eyes i'm wondering how the
show is going to change this will just
have to wait and see episode 3 is titled
Oathbreaker here's the synopsis for that
de nearest meets her future bran meets
the past Tommen confronts the high
Sparrow Arya trains to be no one Varys
finds his answer in ramsey gets a gift
there are a lot of big things happening
in the synopsis but the two biggest seem
like tenaris and brand so I'm wondering
if maybe drogon shows up in the power
balance shifts in the Dothraki because
right now she's queen of nothing they
really don't care about her something
dramatic has to happen if she's going to
win them over of all the things that
donairs could do that would make those
Dothraki people respect her the biggest
would be like a dramatic show of power
and her power is dragons brand meets the
past though this is actually making me
think that we won't see Tower of joy
till episode 3 if we're going to see him
training in episode 2 maybe we'll just
see some white Walker stuff so I'm have
to readjust things I might have to wait
to do my Tower of joy video until next
week but think about it this way if
brand isn't going to see the Tower of
joy incident happen until episode 3
maybe it's because even even though it's
a really big WTF tower joy is a really
big deal they're using it to immediately
precedes like an even bigger reveal on
episode 4 or episode 5 which we'll talk
about in a second because we know the
titles for episodes 4 and 5 so the title
of episode 4 is book of the stranger if
you guys don't know what the stranger is
that's one of the aspects of the seven a
lot of people in the faith of the seven
believe you know there's one God with
many different aspects so people will
pray to different aspects of that God
the jury is kind of out as to whether
they're distinct entities but the
stranger represents death in the unknown
in his description reads a lot like he
might also be a version of the
many-faced God or the many-faced God
might be a more complete explanation of
who the stranger is religions and Game
of Thrones are a lot like religions in
real life you have a lot of different
people
interpreting the same deity in slightly
different ways they have different names
different customs you get the idea i'm
curious to see how the show interprets
that and I think as we're talking about
the book of the stranger the show is
also going to be exploring the idea of
death which means that we might see some
more Jon Snow stuff now the interesting
thing about episode 4 that's different
from some of the other episodes of the
season is that it's a couple minutes
longer now if you remember they've done
this in previous seasons like at the end
of Episode four in its season four we
got that white Walker explainer in the
lands of always winter as they you know
they turn one of Craster's sons into a
white Walker so we might get a scene
like that with a big WTF post-credit
scene so if you consider yourselves part
of the cult that believes that jon
snow's coming back which I I myself I'm
also part of episodes 3 in episodes for
are probably going to be pretty big deal
there is no official episode description
that's been released yet we just know
the title so book of the stranger very
clearly going to be some Arya Faceless
Men stuff happening as well as some Jon
Snow stuff probably that supposedly
episode 5 is called the door that's just
the title so they can apply a lot of
different things like characters
metaphorically are taken to a door they
need to transition to their new roles so
they need to step through the door or
they're stepping through doors like Jon
Snow stepping through the door between
life and death if you've seen any
Fullmetal Alchemist you'll understand
that metaphor open the door to learn the
truth of the universe so a lot of big
stuff probably happening in episode 52
but let me know just based on the
episode titles episode 3 oath breaker
the book of the stranger episode 4
episode 5 the door what do you think is
going to be happening like I said
because we might not see Tower of joy
till episode 3 what I might do for my
bonus video tomorrow is just talk about
the long night the night's king the
history of the White Walkers that kind
of stuff cuz it does sound like we'll
see some white Walker stuff so be sure
to subscribe to get that and there is a
new round of the giveaway that starts
now it's just a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video if there's any bonus videos
that you guys really want me to do just
let me know a lot of it will just depend
on what the episodes actually do but in
case you guys haven't seen it it's been
a while but I actually did a video
talking a little bit about what's going
on in a shy in the Far East stuff as the
show is probably not going to do you can
click here to learn all about that and
you can click here for my episode 1
video thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you